hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
this is terras never seen special guests
Taylor chambers my little brother oh
okay just a few things off the bat we
are recording this at my childhood home
in California and so there's no
microphone or lights so deal with it
will you do a hair flip
it's a thing I do in my videos oh yeah
lunches of all they could put them Sifl
that's why I wear the beanie cuz he it's
too powerful to contain yeah just like
upstaged my entire thing Oh cameras
never seen terminators really good eggs
okay so you see the opening and it's
very easy seems like okay it's like
thick they Lolita okay we understand the
eighties oh you see the butt right off
the bat right but and then shortly after
you see the front as well yeah I know
yeah you see the shadow people which I
feel like yeah I feel like there's not
very many penises in movies it's there's
always like lady parts babies is free
game I'm gonna skew it I got a TMZ thing
in poop there's another movie with um
the guy from the Goblin from from uh I
mean really his early here's a
freakishly large penis and so for it
like in one movie they gave him a fake
penis to like it's too thick kids you
know that there is a name for the wigs
that they use for vaginas to like in
movies when they have to put fake hair
or like make a big push there's like a
name for it does father's listen
oh come on that we kept the wrong the
phone no the couch blanket I could cozy
Seco box blanket I don't know if any of
that
no turn I mean first of all Terminator
comes up to this group of like bad guys
with little switch knives one of those
called switch a switch blade area and
he's like give me your clothes all of
them bro and they're like not man yeah
he's lucky I give y'all your god that is
like it's like who's this little naked
shadow peen man coming out kill he that
kills all him but what he just kills him
so Terminator he just starts terminating
mm-hmm and so obviously treating the
title and this so there's one guy left
and then he then he's like okay yeah oh
yeah no okay you can help these girls do
you give me these oh yeah he's super
quickly upload you can have these I
thought you might owe their clothes
god no race comes onto the picture and
he's the other he's not terminator he's
the other like soldier but he like gets
a police officer and he like knocks we
get swells like what day is it what's
the date and the officer looks so like
offended he's like ah something to say
naked
she's a policeman he's like oh yeah that
to a guy grab everything like runs up to
your babies I got with Daisy tell me the
date everything he says is super like
punch it just punches off Oh what day is
it
yeah please I just put up a lengthy easy
uh May Oh God just go
Sarris shows up she looks like a like an
80s lioness mm-hmm like from that show
Thundercats
yeah Oh like wha what's her name ah she
I think she looks like the main guy lion
let me know
yes Lionel oh no she's like this 80s
feathered goddess out of best book yeah
she has a Vespa which I mean everyone
pretty much had the best one in the
eighties at some point I want one so bad
then Arnold Schwarzenegger goes around
and starts killing all of the Sarah
Connors yeah look cuz he had the
phonebook in back in days that's all you
needed
honestly like I can't even find people
today with my match but he's like got it
I have 20 scared condors in the vicinity
we were saying yeah buddy would be he
doesn't know a lot in know it's like
really demeaning no here's any be
hilarious if he just said no oranges
gurgled no welcome back to the pastures
are Hey Arnold leaving my friend
oh so you see Kyle Reese is such an on
character really can't wreck John we
only care about John who is the son yeah
we thought we was John realizes he does
he fucks mom really yeah I was like
Oedipus ah yeah they they go to the
roommate Sarah Sarah's room and she's
looking to guava shows up yeah like a
few times it's a major player and
occasional source nigger shows up to
Sarah Connors apartment beats up his
roommate and he's looking for Sarah any
pizza theme yeah everything it shows up
he doesn't have any eyebrows where the
hell are his eyebrows dis the heck
appear doors like maybe they got singed
off he there's a fire there's gone
she doesn't have eyebrows he just had
periodically sometimes doesn't have
eyebrows
we'll go from scene to scene to scene we
don't know why which is hilarious
then they fight and then Kyle gets her
and escape from the Terminator so
they're in the police car they stole to
get away from the church to get away
from the Terminator because he attacked
them at the at the bar right and then
John got John had once her way in the
car just grabs out her you're not he's
shown yet like he's like yeah I saw but
he said still he says a punching like he
says is right I'm for the victim on your
side
you suck doing uh-huh he says a good
well she said really she's like oh my
god so she bites it
like with you what else did you do in
that situation
I like the time-travel aspect of this I
recently watched through all three back
to the future have you seen us I've seen
the first one it's a good movie then you
see the eye extraction scene that is
really juicy juicy is the right word
yeah it's disgusting but great like it
looks good until they do the entire face
this shows cuz they had to cut around
his eye to get to it it looks like Mike
Myers it looks like yeah the mask Mike
Myers wears with like a piece cut out
with a robot part mm-hmm yeah it doesn't
look good and then like all of a sudden
they show like a side angle of him and
then back to the front of a Tim again so
Sarah Connors in the hospital and the
Terminator comes to go terminate her and
he shows up at the hospital and he's
like he goes to the front desk and he's
like um I'm I'm a friend of Sarah Connor
skin I see her and the nurse is like oh
doing eight feet and you're obviously
bad you're valuating jackets care man no
she's go man you have a gun you know
Hospital no no was she in the hospital
ever ins me so mad if she wasn't I said
I didn't even watch the movie no that
part I was eating a full bag of kettle
corn and I was very focused on that
you should have learned for 1:30 in the
afternoon like that sometimes that's the
perfect life so then the police officer
is like no you can't see Sarah Connor
and he's like ah feedback that was the
first time he says it oh and it brings
the truck through the door that's right
yeah but I just really wish that I had
catchphrases in my life I'll be back
I'll be back I'll be back I'll be back
ah ah yeah alright bye Taylor
I'll be back he has so many oh so then
Kyle tell Sarah about her son John and
this whole time I thought that his name
was John yeah yeah they don't they don't
really days gave into later very magicus
yeah they just missed his name okay see
he is my brother in every single review
of like I'll own today when it comes
side cuz like they're hiding from the
Terminator cuz after the police station
they drive away and they like hide the
hotel but while they're in there you
know they get snuggly like you do in
hotels when you're hiding for people
right so like they started to do it and
then usually they just they go for it's
almost 80s sex scene I've ever seen am I
like it's like they're not see the
kissing your house believe this it's
just like the whole but like if these
were more luscious I think took that
fake face that they made me for Arnold
and they made each other one and that
they kissed with those up yeah it's very
like turkey face mouth kiss then it's
just like the giant final scene of
Jay fight fight does it make pipe bombs
running away and like it's very dramatic
like they serve us not the effects cuz
listen yeah that was something was
really cool is that it's all practical
effects so like the helicopters going
through like all of the car scenes the
semi-truck Pacific so they blow up the
trip attorney melts and so he's throwing
at them as a skeleton Kyle Noke I'll
blow them up he blows him with a pipe
bomb before his last minute last action
dies he dies Kyle's dead and we didn't
know his name
hold on both I am I feel like we don't
even deserve this God John is dead her
son is dead no it was Cod press is
having the hydraulic press cuz he's
crawling on her cuz he got yeah yeah
yeah cut not the thing he's like calls
out herself scary like screw robot
zombie so it's like fast forwards a
couple months she's pregnant she was
driving around in like her cool Jeep and
she's like talking to herself in this
recorder like what has happened or her
future son John documentary uh-huh it's
like the og podcast a little dramatic to
me the the way she was recording it was
like my name is Sarah Connor and I'm a
lion a pregnant lioness and and I think
everything happened do I tell him do i I
don't know it was very driven
but then the cool seeing the end where
she goes to the gas station the little
boy comes up to her and as I takes her
picture and then it happened to be it's
the picture that how Kyle fell in love
there that picture in the in the future
John her son gave her that photo huh
gave Kyle the photo same photo and
that's how he fell in love with her and
it's cute that he fell in love with her
while she was like with washed in the
glow of her pregnancy with his child
it's kind of it's just a cool like the
story still going on yeah it's a good
ending solid ending solid movie it's
solid for like 80s it's really it's cool
like respectively yeah I really I
enjoyed it I think that number two is
gonna be better cuz I mean it's number
of people say the number two is like the
action film ever made cool sweet oh we
should get a cat there's always a cat in
my videos is it color but she's so furry
in love she's so sweet is she was
napping sorry tiger
tell your you float tiny little salsa
Bowl see you next week we were tripping
here - yeah I would bite him
that's what that's what I do I would do
exactly what you did
[Music]
you